yeah let's always remind people it's the
voters who made this decision thank you
very much ed o'keefe always good to see
you
the busiest atlanta hurricane season on
record ended yesterday
but guess what just in time for the
winter storms in the midwest
the winter weather alerts are up across
ohio this morning snow is already
pounding the state and pounding his word
with up to 18 inches yikes predicted in
some areas
errol barnett is in shaker heights ohio
that's near cleveland wow
errol look at you earl i don't know if
we're ready for snow here in new york
but i guess we need to get ready
what's it like or not gayle here it is
yeah i tell you that the snow here
this has just been relentless all
morning you can see how much snow has
fallen in the past six or eight hours or
so
by the tables and chairs right next to
me and this would be
a winter wonderland if it wasn't so
dangerous
out on the roads driving is precarious
not just here in ohio
but down as far south as kentucky and as
far as
georgia now here in the cleveland area
schools are closed for the day and what
does
a school what does a snow day look like
in the age of covid well some schools
are stopping food pickup so parents
won't be able to get food for their kids
which we know is a real
lifeline for so many people the
expectation
is that 28 million people will feel some
piece of this
massive winter storm system those who
live south of lake areas this whole
thing
pushes east now some encouraging signs
we've seen around here
that there are some of the state's 20
000 snow plows which we see
clearing the roads unfortunately we are
seeing reports of some 20
000 people without electricity which
could be deadly
for the most vulnerable this is already
the most it's expected to be the highest
amount of snowfall in a single day
in december in cleveland in some 15
years
the hope now